la cre et non en ouvre les portes des
clubs
le nouveau quotidien de la directrice de
maternelle ne plus toucher les poignets
elle s'est habituée à utiliser son bras
pour entrer dans la classe depuis la
rentrée scolaire
toutes les portes sont équipés d'un
dispositif anti qu'ovide les enfants se
sont pris au jeu sont plus petits gants
que ils peuvent mettre une grande partie
du bras et avoir beaucoup plus de prise
que nous une installation qui sécurise
l'équipe encadrante
c'est toujours rassurant toute façon
toutes les mesures qui sont prises pour
essayer d'éviter d'avoir des contacts
collectif et qui peut enrayer toute
épidémie
nous on met tout en place on est tout en
un bras c'est vraiment extrêmement
important dans les écoles
cela a été rendu possible grâce à un
jeune guyancourt toi léo morlot away
faire chauffer à mâcher pour danser une
pièce pendant le confinement le jeune en
reconversion se passionne pour les
impressions numériques et propose ses
services à la ville il fallait aider
il y avait le moyen d'aider et en plus
moyen d'apprendre c'est tout bénef en
fait j'ai vu un message passé sur
facebook où aller chercher des gens qui
avaient des imprimantes et pour pouvoir
faire ça et bah bah oui je pensais en
moyenne une petite vingtaine de poignet
était imprimé par jour très école et une
crèche sont déjà équipés à guyancourt
on va déployer sur les maisons de
quartier sur tous les bâtiments qui sont
censés accueillir du public
l'idéal c'est toujours évité les zones
de contact encore on continue à se
protège collectivement pour cela la
mairie a investi 6000 euros
ce dispositif pourra également servir
aux personnes à mobilité réduite